this is what makes me laugh about like
my content my life I say the same [ __ ]
for 15 [ __ ] years and yet nobody
wants to hear that hard work is part of
the equation nobody wants to hear that
patience is part of the equation nobody
wants to hear that bring value to other
people is part of the equation people
for some reason really believe there's
something called Easy Cash There's this
addiction with fast money that [ __ ]
destroys people it's been a good couple
months for you bro real man I'm so happy
man it's [ __ ] great it's [ __ ]
great it's been really fun to watch what
are you guys in town for
impressed man we were impressed radio
well we I did like five interviews today
a bunch of stuff like that man it's been
it's been it's been good it's been good
man yeah you guys good yeah
oh is that right yeah yeah
it was cool that [ __ ] was fun it's been
good you guys been pretty just got
active at it a Z100 that's awesome so a
lot a lot of that's a lot of [ __ ]
plays yeah man a lot of new things man I
like like I've been on the ground for a
while and it's cool to have like that
God it's it's like you're 100 it's and
it's like it's so not guaranteed and
when it comes it's just like
such fun validation and then and then it
starts the next phase which is
the postmortem of this like you gotta
enjoy these 30 days 90 days six days
whatever the [ __ ] it ends up being and
then like all the thoughts of like what
next and how and what it's really cool
it's like just [ __ ] man I'm an
underground artist I wouldn't expect to
have a song on the radio so so it's cool
for me man it's cool to see it and
um I mean I'd love to have another one
but like
that's awesome just as happy to go back
to where I was at well I mean I think
that's gonna that's that's gonna that's
gonna benefit you well
and honestly obviously like everything
this is like all the [ __ ] I give a [ __ ]
about like everything's so different
with distribution and awareness now that
what's really cool is it's all based
kind of on Merit like Z100 in 1989 when
I was a kid nothing was based on Merit
it was all behind the scenes bags and
[ __ ] like politics
Z100 wasn't trying to feel you like the
market made them have to feel you
and that's the best feeling that's my
entire career
everything has been if the people do it
everybody in between you and the people
have to succumb to the truth
my favorite thing is coming out to
places like New York or whatever it is
and meeting the actual people that are
behind everything you know what I mean
it's cool it's like it's like man like
like I'm a normal kid man like I'm from
the Midwest I like I'm not up well the
better part is that those people don't
have as much leverage as they did in
1989. not that I'm mad at them it's just
to me that's the best part because like
the concept of like even having to give
a [ __ ] of being a normal kid from the
Midwest it's just so awesome that you
don't even have to [ __ ] actually kiss
rings of Gatekeepers that way anymore
and again I mean this it's not about
demonizing The Gatekeepers it's just the
way the world works now like the truth
will win
and if you [ __ ] touch the hearts of
enough people you win regardless of like
if they wanted you to win or not or like
where you came from or how or what like
it's [ __ ] a big deal
man I mean underground where I mean I've
had I have a couple Platinum songs who
are you talking to I've been talking to
you forever I know everything about it
but I'm just saying like like I had
never had anything really on the radio
you know no it's really cool like when
you have I always say to like people
that are cool the goal is to have a 63
year old woman know the hook yeah like
when you do that as someone who's really
you know right it's [ __ ] cool this is
actually something I've been thinking a
ton about humans deep need to make
everything vanilla when everything is
not vanilla like we we're back to like
politics and just like life like New
York is so New York is so look seven
minutes in either direction from here
and it's completely different universe
and so like but we need that as humans
because it's too much information but it
[ __ ] everyone up
this place is honestly on some real [ __ ]
if like some weird rule happened that
like you can only be in one place I
don't even think there's a place close
to New York in the world and I've really
traveled the world like that like it's a
special place and I know it because
these last two weeks I was in Bodrum and
Ibiza and like meeting tons of people
randomly little chats like
anybody who's really lived a little bit
and been to places
it's not even like the only people that
don't believe it just haven't been
enough places to contextualize it
really hits me is when I spend a week in
London or LA
and like just compare it to New York
it's so different but people like think
they're close
but they're really not
like at least a wrap at 11 PM
I like that shit's confusing to people
that's very that's the biggest thing I
was thinking about these two weeks when
I was like had some time I think people
are incredibly confused on like how to
win like I'm positive without knowing
[ __ ] that there's an obnoxious amount of
people in the music industry that don't
understand what the [ __ ] going on with
you guys right now
so like that is huge for me I'm excited
that the ground is Shifting like so
Instagram
becoming Facebook
excites me because it [ __ ] up a lot of
people who only have one pitch
Mike
people people who made it on Instagram
and don't want like I'm always good at
not being romantic of what got me there
that's a strength of mine
so I like when [ __ ] resets because the
establishment or even the new
establishment struggles with the
transition because they're comfortable
in their cozy win people that want on
MTV people that want on c100 people that
want on MySpace people that want a
Spotify SoundCloud Instagram now this is
going to be the tick tock generation in
six years when Tick Tock becomes in what
Instagram is right now and there's a
transition for all those people they're
gonna be like yo [ __ ] this is how I made
it this is how I figured it out so the
Instagram
generation being [ __ ] up right now is
a very good thing for me because it
resets the deck so you have an emerging
Tick Tock crew they that are like
getting that are emerging from the
emerging to The Establishment you have
an Instagram Crew That's The
Establishment that now is starting to
wane off and get a little bit longer on
the tooth and are scared it shows you it
really has value and and skill at I
think value is absolutely right skill
hunger
people get soft after winning a lot of a
lot of people don't understand like a
lot of people just watch a lot of people
just want one not one big moment
one one big moment to make some money
and chill and coast and that's amazing
that's fine web 3 is a little different
web three right now
was on some different [ __ ] altogether
last year was about
exactly what happened with the internet
in 1999
70 percent
some mix of opportunistic
so all opportunistics see the moment
cooker [ __ ] about anything but making a
bag which I don't really genuinely it's
not my jam but I don't judge I think
wall Street's that I think Bankers are
that like it's just about money and I'm
not here to judge but that was like all
the way that was like the 80 percent
were that all the way to complete con
artists 80 percent
scammers to I just care about making
four million dollars now to buy a
[ __ ] Lamborghini and be out
the the nft yeah all of it web three
right so 80 that
if not 90.
the reason I don't go to 90 is I would
argue 10 percent
which is the 90 where people with better
intentions but not realizing that's what
they were doing I think they just like
like like they believed that their jpeg
was worth a drillion with no bad
intentions they genuinely believed it
and those are people who don't
understand timing and how long real [ __ ]
has to form and then within the ten
percent
that's left many thoughtful people of
that 10 80 Straight Tech nerds real you
know genuine technologists who really
care about the tech and they're in it
they've been in it since 17 they are in
it and then a very small group that
looks like me
that is like the same way that almost
everybody in social media in 2006 when I
hit the scene literally behind my back
ninety percent of the conversation was
that guy is going to be gone in six
months come and gone and I would hear it
in the way that I would hear it and I
would always laugh I'm like I'm the only
one that's still going to be here in 15
years that's the most interesting that's
the people I tried to spend as much time
with and find which is like people that
really know the score
are putting the pieces down to win 2037
not 2021 and
um and that's why we're in this place
right now because when 80 to 90 percent
of something are doing the wrong thing
for as quick as possible you're gonna
have Peaks and that's what and now and
that's what and that's why I love it
right now like I'm really enjoying this
moment other than some people bought be
friends at a price and now it's under
water and that [ __ ] [ __ ] with me
heavy because anybody who bought it from
the original mints winning heavy even
with the [ __ ] bear even with the
[ __ ] Market it's people that caught
it in the hype at the top and I even
though that's not who I sold it to right
I sold it to people that meant it
every one of them in a bear market right
now is winning heavy
I'm still Associated an emotional
who bought it off somebody
so besides that part which [ __ ] with me
because I give a [ __ ] but I'm very loud
of like stick with me here and I'm gonna
win that game in seven years when it
when I'm winning and it's winning
if people sold next week I'm gonna be
like I [ __ ] told you not to
you know and so like so I love this time
because now all the building gets done
and this is what happened in 2000 and I
built Wine Library for my dad in 2000
2001 2002 because everybody ran from the
internet because it was a fad because
the stock market crashed
and that's exactly what everyone's doing
right now everyone's like C C bless you
everyone's like C C prices are way down
right world of women were [ __ ] 80 000
now they're four thousand and that's
like a you know if you want some some
[ __ ] at seventy thousand that's four
thousand
and most people bought it 70 000 bought
because her friend told them to they
didn't have any homework any like so
right now is when all the interesting
like I promise you when we see each
other in 10 years and I'm sure we will
in different places different situations
I'll bring this up be like hey
whatever's winning then straw or wine
glass or whatever project I'm like that
[ __ ] [ __ ] happened in 2023 like if
this is the time that good [ __ ] happens
because we get to learn we got the
context all the hucksters go and start
doing every huckster that was pedaling
nfts that could give a [ __ ] about nfts
right now is trying to figure out what
else like they're trying to sell some
other [ __ ] man I think a big problem was
everyone was given access to going part
of this [ __ ] if everyone had a friend
who's into it everyone knows that one
friend who loves nfts or loves some sort
of investment and they're like yo you
gotta get into this and then all the
people with no knowledge of it were
getting into it
maybe wait maybe like real estate stock
market
sports cards sneakers like Jeweler like
people for some reason really believe
there's something called easy cash
for some [ __ ] reason
people really somehow think they're
gonna find some [ __ ] seconds
moment in time that they figured like
there's this addiction with fast money
that [ __ ] destroys people and and
sometimes there is that moment correct
it is come on they see that and then but
anybody so many friends do that man
where where like a [ __ ] coin or
something would blow up because I had so
many friends in the throated I heard
about this because I was really into
stocks and puts calls all that [ __ ] I
was good at that and then they're all
like yo nfts man all this crypto like
you know about it all my friends are
trying to get into it these kids didn't
have like this you know a little bit of
a disposal income and I was like man I
don't think you should but everybody 99
of people that make fast cash with no
skill involved lose it
I don't understand how people like no
this is what makes me laugh about like
my content my life
I say the same [ __ ] for 15 [ __ ] years
and yet nobody wants to hear that hard
work as part of the equation nobody
wants to hear that patience is part of
the equation nobody wants to hear that
bring value to other people is part of
the equation they're like what about
great I'm like that's called
entertainment entertainment is one of
the highest forms of value even being
attractive modeling is escaping somebody
like there's there needs to be a value
exchange and and like unless like a lot
of people that make content one of the
reasons Tick Tock is so fascinating is
Instagram was so easy for so many people
it was a [ __ ] photo
right and like so like shit's always
gonna change but I'm just fascinated by
the addiction to like I'm I laugh at the
person that thinks they're the one
that's gonna figure out the fast scale
I'm like what in your history has ever
shown you that you're gonna outsmart the
world you've been losing consistently
because you're looking for a scam
so so
yeah when I was in college I worked for
a startup accelerator and every single
business I ever worked with
we would base the strategy off of a
comparable and and that helped me
realize that it's like anything you ever
want to do someone has done it a hundred
percent anything you ever want to do
someone has the only thing that you
could it's like food at a restaurant the
only thing you can do is tweak the what
I call Sprinkles you're not going to
invent the cake or the cupcake but you
might be the first one that says what
about Ginger instead of sugar you might
be the first one that says wait a minute
like bacon on top of a cupcake might
[ __ ] with people and they might love it
but you're not going to be the one that
creates the cupcakes so so it's
literally every anytime anyone comes
with me with a business idea I say dude
look it up has someone done it before if
they haven't I don't think it's gonna
happen if it's gonna work the only time
that gets uh challenged and that's
what's happening with web3 is when new
things happen for example
Uber I was very close to
the fact that the iPhone had been
invented and now was in enough people's
hands changed rules that people said it
wouldn't happen that's why the
blockchain's such a big deal that's why
web 3 and nfts is a big deal technology
the internet can't do what the
blockchain can do thus it renders new
[ __ ] that we're all gonna think isn't
gonna work so to your point I fully
agree other than when there's such a
significant technology that happens you
know what I think what's that brother
yeah of course I mean like and it's just
like you think about [ __ ] like um
how profound
the car was and when it went from being
a rich person's item to everyone I think
about space travel right right now
nobody's going to space except those 17
guys right what happens in 100 years
when everyone is
like a hundred years from now when going
to [ __ ] space is like going to Kansas
from New York
what does that do like what does that
change what does that mean that's the
[ __ ] that gets me excited like if you
showed somebody that was born like
living our age right now 100 years ago 8
1923. if you show them our life right
now it would make their [ __ ] skull
melt whatever had a microwave when
everyone got a microwave no phone no TV
no car like anything no internet nothing
we nothing yeah
all the time what's up brother my
grandmother's 96. oh my God you're so
lucky to have her right I just asked her
questions all day long yeah she's like
we didn't have a refrigerator she's like
I used to pee outside the house we
didn't have a [ __ ] running bat my mom
because I was born in Russia so that was
like 50 years behind my mother's
childhood the bathroom was outside
I grew up I I was born in Belarus which
is now Belarus now people know what that
is
I moved I moved to Queens when I was
three okay and then we I moved to Jersey
when I was six and I grew up in Jersey
so she grew up I'm an East Coast
Security speaking English yeah I mean
spoke Russian in the house and under I
mean I'm fluent in Russian uh but but
yeah grew up but you know I don't know
like immigrant life is funny because the
whole world is America but your four
walls inside your house is wherever your
family's from and it creates some cool
[ __ ] Dynamics like my friends would
come over maybe like can I can we get
like chicken nuggets and my mom's like
we've got borscht what the [ __ ] you know
like that would be like fun [ __ ] like
like my mom would make like a burger and
it would be like this like there's an
Eddie Murphy skit of like the way his
grandmother made a burger like eggs and
peppers and my mom's Burger was like
this thick like it was like [ __ ] like
so like that shit's always fun yeah but
yeah I'm an East Coast kind of like
um
Swiss German I mean so cool
and your mom and my mom uh grew up in
Rochester Minnesota yeah she grew up the
same Hometown where I grew up worked
actually my first job ever was at his
Pharmacy my mom worked there back no way
back I love that so I have much older
parents much older parents is that right
so so when I was born my mom was 42 my
dad was 60.
was that their second marriage or their
first my dad had uh I have half siblings
my dad this is my dad's second second
marriage and your mom's first so I was
basically an only child
and um it was it was it I don't know it
was interesting but growing up there and
in Minnesota but they both work at Mayo
Clinic uh well my mom had a private
practice but
she basically was the psychiatrist
therapist for the doctors that didn't
want to be so interesting
and what kind of kid were you like what
were you into
there you go and I was um
skater skater kid scared
but hockey
it's you're like forced yeah you're not
allowed to like Minnesota
um and then and then a high school when
I was a [ __ ] boy man
you know hustling yeah
what was driving that you think uh just
you know man like I guess my my parents
get don't give me an allowance or
anything like go do your thing my first
job was at age 14. we did a pharmacy
he wanted more I want more so and you
know weed and you know and just I don't
know like like in Minnesota it was like
like everybody there in Rochester was
just like it was the killer I grew up
around skater kids you know it was like
you know awesome it was a culture
everyone either wanted to go pro at
skating or go to college and it was one
of the two how tall are you by ninth
grade uh by ninth grade I want to say
something I was I was always almost
thought I would say it's weird that's
weird because I I think in high school I
was like six three six six four I was I
was the tallest but then weirdly like
once I went to college like getting over
two inches wow oh really yeah yeah so I
was six six I was the tallest and then I
became like
taller
now I'm like certified you're like a
tall too
it's all by everyone's standards yeah
yeah it was good man Rochester Minnesota
good plays great people I went to
University of Wisconsin which was quite
amazing my personal trainer Mike Picante
grew up in Minnesota and went to
Wisconsin yeah
I love Midwestern people man it's a
great place to grow up I agree I like
Midwest nice
yeah I own a Call of Duty team in
Minnesota
I did Vicon in Minnesota I love
Minnesota you know I was I was there I
did a surprise
yeah man what I heard it's crazy it's
[ __ ] awesome how did you feel about
throwing it in Minneapolis loved
my so I loved it so much that vcon is a
three-year conference came with the nft
and the plan was to make it travel and
I'm like currently like debating to
maybe doing in Minnesota again I really
like Minnesota it has some of the best
people man the restaurant scene has
gotten much stronger in the last 10
years
I don't know if you've been famous after
them yeah but we're going to open up the
graveyard and we've been talking about
opening a restaurant in Minneapolis is
that right I mean it's the early days
but but it's starting to brew as a combo
in Minneapolis I mean like how often do
you get back there I I mean I I have an
apartment in Minneapolis awesome
Rochester which is an hour away and I um
just know the whole scene there I know
everyone so well but it's it's it's been
on my mind for a while and if I could
just find someone to run it yeah to run
it's like to do business well like I
said marketing branding's my bread and
butter like can I give you a hot one on
that something that really works for me
is making a piece of social content
describing exactly what I want to happen
and then putting in my URL in my profile
a Google form that is very very very
distinctly asking the right questions so
that for the team you can get down
between you doing like a one and a half
minute this is what I'm looking for in a
partner
whatever the [ __ ] in your heart I want
you to be from born and bred in
Minnesota like whatever it is then if
you're interested
click the link in my bio and then that
is like really detailed like whatever
that could be the case
that then lets the team
very efficiently we do this a lot yeah
it's a Google form you get to ask the
questions Tyler can like he's done a
million times for me you can
really really get to a place where
your crew whomever that may be assuming
some of the people yeah so you guys can
you guys can really get to a good place
of like oh here are the final four and
then you can shop up feel the chemistry
it's really effective
I feel like a lot of
a lot I think you're on to something
though I really I really feel like it
continues to gain momentum as a as a
culinary theme
so many and there's still so much more
demand I still feel like it's six or
seven yeah I still feel like they're six
to seven
short like there's six to seven
meaningful restaurant bars still need to
be built for it to like fill up the
demand
every time I'm there I'm like there's
more here
so I really like that all right yeah I'm
a big fan
I'm like desperate desperate desperate
for the Jets to have a good season
because they play first week of December
I like DC too yeah yeah you know I
didn't spend enough time
DC's like it's a great everything the
food seems good food seeds really good
it was a great it is right but now it's
like there's a lot of room there there's
a lot of room to do [ __ ] politicians
suck [ __ ] so that [ __ ] up the whole
vibe it's only like a small part but it
like eats up the whole [ __ ] energy
right it's a party when you're like
there go all right okay
you're unique in the fact that like this
is what always from afar made me
gravitate is
blindly the concept of actually being
unique but also having enough
entrepreneurial DNA to let that
uniqueness scale is very rare because
you're either
such an artist that you don't have a
[ __ ] entrepreneurial bone in your
body and then you're not able to put the
pieces together right
it's like they want to be so they want
to be so hard and they like their
ideology is so deep like [ __ ]
commercialism
which is fine like to each their own but
they can't get there
well it's popular but I'll also love
like what's you know underground or
things that I've Loved growing up like
like just older music and then bringing
all that together
what became my style I totally
understand with none of us
not even your closest with yourself in
the mirror
if I asked you like no [ __ ]
what percentage would have you given
yourself a year ago with yourself in
your own thoughts on some real [ __ ] of
actually having a radio song What
percentage do you think you would have
given for real for real I'm actually
genuinely curious I mean I will
probably biased because my lyrics are
completely obscene I'm sorry A lot of
the time
the original version of the song like
yeah I mean like people don't want to
hear a song on the radio where every
fifth word is completed out
um
but I've always thought of myself as an
underground Irishman I came on a
SoundCloud rapper a lot of my
Inspirations are like you know suicide
boys XXX it's all these artists that
aren't really radio artists where where
streaming took over and it was like it's
not even really something we even think
about you know I I never really thought
about that as even a a lane that I never
get into you know I just just you know
it didn't even cross my mind yeah it
makes sense and then and then
why asked because I understand what
you're saying I
15 years ago was it was very clear to me
that everybody on Earth would know who I
was and I would never have a TV show or
a movie
if someone asked me the question that I
just asked you which is why I asked you
the question
the real answer to me would be there's a
37 chance that I will have the business
Show on Netflix that does to Shark Tank
what the voice did to American Idol
so I you see where I'm going that's what
we're going that's why I asked you and
for me 15 years ago I was like everybody
on Earth is going to know who I am
because I know what the internet's about
to do and this is what I'm gonna do
and and I will never be on TV or in a
movie the way you needed to be to
actually get there
comma I know that if the right thing's
put in front of me if I if that spidey
sense thing that I have says yes my
ideology or strategy will become
secondary to the fact that I know it's
the moment to go yeah and then it
becomes the like when the voice launched
American Idol was at its height
yeah and Shark Tank is an Undisputed
business show of Pop Culture but it's
long in a tooth now and you just know
that there's something that's gonna
happen which is where my brain goes and
I think like I'm that person but I'm
equally back to your point and I sense
the energy like thrilled if that never
happens because it's not needed
but that's why I asked I was wondering
if like you ever thought it could be in
the cars I mean looking back on it I
mean I've I've always thought of myself
as a SoundCloud rapper underground
artist but I never expected that you
know the song about the radio I never
expected that like I could become sort
of this like [ __ ] sex symbol or
whatever it is man I mean shout out to
social media for all that where else I
got like you've never seen yourself in
the mirror
[Laughter]
that's six six [ __ ] pretty face
you know what honestly growing up man I
thought I had a [ __ ] voice my voice I
was like man I have a weird voice out
there anyone would ever listen to my
music I didn't realize that my voice was
like low and like unique and all that
and I don't know my music I was like you
know I'm just being weird and different
this shit's not gonna go mainstream
I mean I'm I'm I guess a perfect example
is x axis X R.I.P he he had this music
that was so out of the ordinary and so
ignorant and crazy and beautiful but you
know what you know what the connection
because well it blew up well
I would argue it blew up because it was
uncomfortably honest like you when you
heard it you were like I believe this
[ __ ] to my bones
that but it's also so like undeniably
like good
good like like a gel but you can't
really say objectively good but it's
like that [ __ ] [ __ ] Banks and that
was a sound that never reached the
mainstream or reached the radio but
influenced an entire generation you're
influencing a shitload of people and
then and then if someone like that can
influence everybody then it's like well
the radio looks and they're like you
know what I guess well like I mean I
mean I mean
anyone back to the earlier question
anyone that believes
an actor on a network television show
thank you the number one actor the
leading actor and actress on a network
television show Thursday night on NBC at
9pm
there's not a single actor leading a
network television show from 8 P.M to 11
Monday through Friday on ABC CBS or ABC
CBS or NBC right now none of the leading
actors Monday to Friday 8 pm to 11 that
could even compete in any shape or form
with the average b-list Tick Tock
celebrity for fame it's not even close
think about that there's not an actor
like people like so that goes back to
like the whole point when the rules get
re-fucking triggered if you told
Hollywood 15 years ago that Ace like an
upper echelon tick tocker in 15 years is
more famous than the leading actor of
Thursday night NBC 9 p.m I can't even
ready for this as I'm telling you this
right now as we go into August into
September the fall lineup
I don't think I know
an actual Network show
I know the streaming shows Netflix
celebrities I know never have I ever I
can tell you all about that but I can't
tell you what the [ __ ] on CBS
I don't need I would love to I would
love them
to your point like with with Tick Tock
and all that man like I think we
yesterday we were walking back from an
interview we walked through Soho and I
want to say within 10 minutes I don't
know one
maybe two blocks we walked yep I took
about 30 to 40 pictures of course and
every single person that's right was
talking about
Sherry Monty 100 specifically 100
where it's like I'm a rapper and they
know my music they're like oh yeah I
love this song but it's like the main
focus
man a hundred percent is the biggest
thing now thank you it's not even close
and when I started yelling about tick
tock four years ago you should have seen
the [ __ ] people were saying to me pop
immediately took over my generation East
Coast right like like immediately like I
was very much into like a twisted sister
and like like that whole like Jersey
stuff and then like Bon Jovi and then
like
immediately on impact of Run DMC and
Beastie Boys it was like I will never
listen yeah same 86. and so then I like
The Fat Boys because I liked humor and I
just thought it was like super funny but
then then where it got serious Public
Enemy was very serious because it was
because I was really into like history
and social like geopolitic like like
race and gender and politics and Society
the first time I ever bought on iTunes
was harder than anything oh first song I
ever bought so that was like whoa this
is super different and then and then
Big Daddy Kane
krs-1 was like oh this is different and
then everything completely of course
Snoop and Dre and like Wu-Tang was super
interesting like I was like
when you look at the candy Karis one
cares one's repertoire is enormous
enormous
extremely small very
and then and then
when when Biggie's album came out I was
a freshman in college
and I and my friend Joe Manukau who
works at V friends P like my whole crew
we're still to this day my dearest
friends
he was an unsigned hype so it was all
about it so finally came out
and
talk about someone whose lyrics will I
literally thought at the end of the
album that Biggie and I were friends
that we like grew up together like it
was so Crystal Clear for real yeah like
I could see the poster hanging on his
wall like you know like like it was like
I like left the first listen through I
was like
this is so different
so that was like game changing that
happened at the same time that one of my
best friends in the world Rob moose I
call him
um
he was so into underground you got to
remember this is pre-internet
and he was getting bootleg
tapes
and he was listening to Scarface and
Ghetto Boys and Bun B and [ __ ] yeah
and so like but this was 1994. so there
is no internet
there's no internet so you don't know
MTV's not covering this [ __ ] bet is not
on most people's TVs and it's rarely and
so like at that time
I moved to New York in 96 to go to
college I went to Liu in Brooklyn so I
would go downtown Brooklyn you'd walk to
the corner
all of those cassettes were available
for two dollars 100 100
wow yeah two year Osborne nobody he's
always been one of my favorite rappers
nobody knew any of that stuff like and
then
and so like all that sound like No Limit
like I remember we went to LA
uh one summer during college and we went
to Roscoe's and there's a No Limit I'm
not even sure I'm not sure
I think we did yeah uh we're on the way
yeah and there was a no limit like like
Hummer like dressed out Hummers that we
like literally Rob took 170 000 photos
yeah
Master P and like and and so that whole
Houston like South because remember it's
94 so the whole Atlanta thing hadn't
happened yet and I was like and I
remember like all the LA kids and all
the New York kids like being because who
were like I would call deeper into hip
top yeah there was all well first of all
that was all happening then yeah but the
I remember vividly like playing Madden
and NBA live maybe you know that's all
you did you played seven hours of video
games we played Spades and Selah like I
went to like Hood College and
I remember actively listening and
watching because that's all I've ever
done my whole life and being fascinated
by how much people [ __ ]
on that music because it was like so
different and they like and I remember
them saying this is whack this is
[ __ ] garbage and I remember because
Rob would just keep playing it because
it was his [ __ ] no no no biggie was
[ __ ] instant smash Scarface Ghetto
Boys Bun B the whole Southern [ __ ] got
it 94. pre-outcast pre like 94. I
remember when it was more not even
Atlanta it was more like Houston I
remember Louisiana like I remember
something that I'll never forget I've
never said this out loud I've never
really even like I've only talked about
this to myself I never really had this
combo I remember every it would come on
Rob's like listen to this listen this
people would [ __ ] on it
and I remember
an hour into video game play
people were moving to it and I remember
like vividly being like this is
interesting
they're [ __ ] on it and they like it
and when they're not paying attention
they like it and as soon as somebody
would be like yo they're like No And
like I remember that
it's crazy how that that
culture still exists everywhere it's
like oh if it's cool to hate on
something yeah but there's jammingly
good [ __ ] actually in that whole story
line I forgot the actually probably the
biggest moment when Nas dropped
it [ __ ] was bananas that Jay-Z song
where he gives love to everybody and he
talks about that little moment
he's right about what he said it was so
much better than anything else that had
ever come out that I feel like every
rapper was like I need to retire I mean
going back to Travis Porter I was like
you guys need to get Diana Ross to do a
song with you like the baby I was like
yo like you like you need to like find
like like a little Richard before like
like I still believe that I still I
still believe right right now
the number one move is to convince
Stevie Wonder to do a song with you like
I love that man I'm sampling those
artists and and I think a lot of those
I don't think people realize how much
Smokey Robinson would say yes to
something right now because a lot of
those guys and gals want one more moment
all of you are so young but the world is
so young that you're in you've already
had multiple moments where someone said
who's that oh yeah and you're like what
someone called lord and oldie and I was
like yeah I'm gonna need you to take
that back right now
it's funny because I have these fans
that that will be like oh oh I'll listen
to Grammy in high school and then and
then now they're in college dude some
guys guys tell them how old what that
kid that asked me for the selfie what he
said how old he was when he started this
kid just said can I he goes like can I
have a photo I was like sure kid's super
young he's like yo I've been watching
you since I was nine I was like
I was like nine I know how you
[ __ ] said I've been watching
him since nine I'm like am I a thousand
but if you think someone's been
oh my God it's absurd it's cool to see
to see fans I'm sure you have the exact
same thing where it's where they grow
older but they don't they don't move on
to our other things they become bigger
fans they hear your new [ __ ] they watch
you evolve and they [ __ ] love it yeah
the genre that I'm in is so interesting
because
um
right here so a lot of my friends who
have enormous amounts of Fame when
they're with me they're always really
fascinated by the way people react when
they interact with me and after a while
I finally put a pinpoint on it what's
super weird about making content that's
talking about real [ __ ]
is they don't like you because you're
good at a sport or you're giving them
escapism like the reason music is so
powerful is like life's hard for so many
people and getting like three minutes of
a burst of like escapism is powerful or
like a half an hour of an hour with an
album it's like really matters for a lot
of people especially adolescents
for me almost all of my love usually
comes from a place of admiration because
it's actually done something for them
which is what music does actually touch
on a little bit more I think than film
and actors and athletes which is why I
think music has that because albums
especially when they are the kind of
albums that speak to me are really
manifestos
[Music]
um
but you're absolutely right when you got
something that you're bringing in value
consistently to people and it's also
like a it's also I mean I just tweeted
this out yesterday randomly because I
was flying and like that's when I get to
listen to more music like
Redbone by Childish Gambino like I
listened to that song
29 times in the last 48 hours nice 29
times
Pursuit of Happiness like like when
something brings you value and whatever
from a music standpoint the sheer amount
of consumption now a lot of people do
watch like friends in Seinfeld to go to
sleep too you know my my friends my
friend Joe Tokyo Joe who I brought up a
bunch tonight yeah he literally watched
he would literally listen that's like 24
7. but like literally he would watch
Goonies every night to go to sleep every
night yeah yeah but then that's like
going on I think I think it's background
noise I think people need this yeah it's
Comfort literally I live to be 90 and
spend the last 10 years of my life going
to the horse track having some weird
nickname like one-eyed Gary because I
lost an eye somewhere between now and
90. Anita in La I used to do it on
simulcast from Boston like like I'm like
I was a degenerate like I'm I was 38
seconds for being in the mafia yeah like
in college like every like I would be at
the TR instead of going to class in
college I would literally go to Suffolk
Downs at like 11 30 in the morning Mount
Ida College in Newton Mass I would
literally go to Suffolk Downs at 11 30
in the morning
on a Tuesday literally
degenerates would be there and after
several months like we were family you
know they were like yeah One-Eyed Willy
was good like like you know so like I
would like and I would get there at 11
30 and I would leave at 11 30 at night
way yeah but because I would have salmon
Santa Anita yeah would go on at like 4
P.M gotta say to 7 30 oh 7 30 Penn
National oh I was like 13 seconds away
from being a [ __ ] a girl
[Music]